[Applause]
I love you
I love you and you happy Thursday
everyone it's only been 23 hours but I
missed you so much
watching you sleep on hidden camera just
isn't the same oh I love it when they
twitch
so why are cities in such big trouble
let's start with San Fran also known as
the bidet by the Bay
you got people pooping in public and so
much retail theft stores just straight
up closed the only thing they weren't
stealing from Walgreens was toilet paper
then there's the crazy deal for
reparations five million to every
eligible black adult guaranteed incomes
of 97 Grand for 250 years in homes for
just one dollar a family
to get a sweet deal like that you used
to need the last name Biden
after violence and homelessness
Skyrocket especially in minority
communities it's like instead of solving
the problems before them they offered
pie in the sky idiocies that will
destroy this city for good hey should we
call an exterminator for this termite
problem nah let's burn down the house
instead
ironically this version of reparations
could cause another civil war it's a
wholesale force transfer of property and
money from innocent families
we fought a war over attacks on T the
reparations deal makes that look like an
argument over a parking spot meanwhile a
CNN reporter's car got robbed in San
Fran the police said the only thing the
criminal got away with was a laptop
filled with fake news
terrible and from the description the
perp sounds like a desperate loser with
no respect for the law
shortly after a former police
commissioner says becoming victimized is
part of the basic City life so embrace
it that's like having a fire chief say
he's tired of your whining about arson
you know I'm sorry with those sexy
window treatments maybe your house was
asking for it
it was them
and where the homeless crisis is so bad
vagrants just parked tents in
residential neighborhoods now and now
those residents want to move away I
haven't seen that many tents pitched
since I auditioned for Chippendales
[Laughter]
glad my mom's not here to see this now
there are counties in Oregon wanting to
join Idaho just so they're not
associated with Portland so it's not
just people wanting to flee but actual
counties you know folks are fed up when
they dump you for the bright lights of
Boise
but it's a smart move for folks who
prefer potatoes over meth though they're
both great with bacon bits and sour
cream
and here at NYC every commute you got a
50 50 chance of running into a
psychopath on the subway and I'm not
even talking about the train Jesse takes
but I guess being attacked on a subway
sure beats being thrown in front of one
and of course you got Chicago LA and DC
where drugs gangs and murder are as
plentiful as generic Cialis at The
Villages
so why this summary because I realized
there isn't the counterpart of crazy
cities on the right isn't that strange I
mean usually in every issue there's
always a yin and yang of left and right
by the way yin and yang were Hunter's
connections at that Chinese Energy
company
[Applause]
order
Texas guns there's always this duopoly
of left and right but not here we only
hear of cities run by crazy lefties but
not crazy righties you don't hear
Morning Joe screeching about mobs of
cowboys dropping Deuces on the sidewalks
in Great Falls Montana
and when tents pop up there it's where
they're supposed to pop up in the woods
on the weekends when people are camping
and being eaten by bears
so why is that where are the crazy
right-wing towns do they even exist I
wonder what one would look like
Wing hell home
our citizens are forced to commute to
work without being robbed your assault
assaulted homeless encampments are
nowhere to be found the place where
family values run rampant resulting in
disgusting
town full of people respecting the cops
in the military witness the horrorist
children as young as five are forced to
play
and the local government has the balls
to stay out of your business those
scumbags are too busy wasting tax
dollars on proper sanitation improving
schools and incentivizing small business
right-wing hell Halls it's a nightmare
where no one gets out alive
[Music]
fair and balanced and unafraid
but you know we can dream but sadly
cities just become more blue and less
red and also plain worse than the people
in charge call it progress but it's not
it's sad because it's preventable see a
great City needs two strong oppositional
parties because that keeps their own
excesses in check you ever see a
bachelor before he's married he's a
disgusting mess smelling a body odor
desperation and bad drugs
then he gets married and suddenly he
cleans up his act or in cat's case
cleans up her act
[Laughter]
that's what the cities need they need to
settle down with a good old-fashioned
right-wing husband
not Anthony I don't want it I don't want
it save your applause
so maybe that's why there's no
right-wing City you know where their
lunatics run the streets and their
leaders do nothing while crime explodes
the unmarried left has already that has
already have that covered and they're
doing a bang-up job on their own you go
girl
[Applause]
tonight's guess
he speaks that truth like a geyser and
has hair like the Heat Miser Fox News
contributor in Washington Times opinion
editor Charlie heard
[Applause]
he's like an Italian hero crusty cheesy
and covered with a thin layer of oil
comedian Joe DeRosa
and when she makes it rain it's usually
the tears of her axis boxers contributor
captain
[Applause]
and he doesn't Bowl because it's
impossible to rent bowling shoes in 91
extra wide my massive sidekick in the
NWA World Heavyweight Champion Tyrese
should have been better than that
Charlie
Am I Wrong are there any like of the of
the counterpart uh right-wing cities
where like if a liberal goes there they
were there they would lose their
what he would go there and go my God
this is two right wing for me I mean you
could save parts of Florida but I mean
it's like it doesn't really impinge on
your life no and and that's because
these cities are the the final
culmination of literally 50 years of the
best
ideas Democrats have to offer
um you know you know going back to lbj's
Great Society and the war on poverty and
everything and quite frankly it's why
after 20 50 years
um you know Democrats are so obsessed
with talking about race because race is
something that they can't do anything
about what you can do something about is
actually have have cities and have a
government that works but since all of
their ideas are so terrible and none of
them work you wind up they have no
choice but to talk about race race
covers up for class
you know that's a very serious point it
right now that's why I said it Charlie
that's why that's why they can't talk
about classes and that's why Donald
Trump is such has been such a threat to
them as well as to Republicans because
he walked in and completely scrambled
everything and became you know stepped
out of the duopoly yeah and uh talked
about ideas that appeal very much to to
Democrat voters and Republican voters
exactly uh Joe you are a small business
owner not just a small comedian
okay
but but a small business owner you own a
sandwich shop yeah downtown yes called
Joe's Joey roses thanks for doing a
second of research
Hold On by the way let me just let's
just take a Beat
just want to give the at-home audience a
chance to start typing before
no I'm uh
um okay ready go okay
uh has the city changed much has it
gotten better do you were have you have
you been a victim of crime you're
shopping the idea that there are no
cities in red states that are like this
is insane it's it's absolutely not true
I was just in Louisiana Louise ends are
very red States yeah a lot of these same
issues I was in several cities I love
the people I like the cities a lot of
these similar problems are happening uh
have I seen a change in New York no it's
New York New York is considered a
hipster city right we get that label a
lot how did you get here
we get that label a lot in New York oh
hipster New York hipster New York well
guess what nobody in New York is
bitching and moaning about any of this
stuff because this is a real Metropolis
oh that's wrong no it's not oh you've
got you got it you know what you got to
get down with the real people this is
part of hanging out in your sandwich
shop this is part of the landscape here
crime filth we accept it you sound like
the police commissioner huh you sound
like the police commissioner and that
guy made a great point you live in a
city you take what comes to you that's
what it is that's what it is
a crime I will take crime and culture
over one of your boring ass red State
suburbs the point is the simple a the
cities that you're talking about
actually still run by liberals even
though they're in red States and number
two okay you would feel differently if
you were paying so many taxes for the
services that should keep you safe I
agree there's danger and risk to every
city but if you're paying tens of
thousands of dollars in taxes and you
still feel unsafe that's a problem yeah
but I I think it's I I yes I think it's
a deeper conversation than we can get to
in these in these I destroyed you
I'm happy to build my time this is good
yeah are you enjoying this
oh good I don't know maybe I should move
over to this side no we're good yeah
I was hoping you'd back me up a little
bit well I I was with you but you're
talking about New Orleans and that's
unfortunately a little blue Problem
Child yeah that's why I live on the side
of a long bridge with two police forces
paid by my taxes so it's tough to get
there yeah but but what about Baton
Rouge is that it's the same but it's not
as bad as New Orleans because it's the
policies that hurt right so if you have
a police force your crime rate's not as
high but in New Orleans at one point we
were down to 800 police officers for the
City of New Orleans yes that's a problem
but you know I was going to talk about
reparations oh please do so yeah because
you know I'm kind of you know I'm
probably interested in that
listen first of all
there's a little key word in there
before you get your feathers all ruffled
up those who qualify yes so we then
you're gonna have that fun thing of
being like how black are you okay and
did your ancestors maybe come through
Canada or Jamaica or somewhere else or
do they come right afterwards or even
worse what if cats
great-great-great-grandfather was a
slave yeah
does she get her reparations now she
could you could she should yeah see what
I'm saying because the DNA and genetics
yeah but here's the thing about
reparations what reparations was
intended for was what did everybody do
back then they farmed yeah farm lands so
40 acres in a mule was an opportunity
for you to compete build wealth and have
a seat at the table because the
African-Americans we just want to sit at
the table we don't want you to buy our
meal we'll take care of that ourselves
even if we have to bring the table what
reparations is now in this country it's
called opportunity because that's what
40 acres in a meal was it was giving us
the opportunity to compete so now we
have the opportunity I'm sitting here
this is my reparations I took that and
ran with it so we don't need the
reparations we've got the opportunity
this is a scam just like anything else
because I guarantee if we watch the
people who are planning this watch their
bank accounts watch them all sudden
they're baby daddies all of a sudden
don't get awesome security jobs and
mansions pop up and planes are because I
got a fly to look for us right right
they got to find the ones that qualify
that's true so it's you know and it's
everything we see in religion the pastor
starts at church he ends up with a
private jet yeah and everyone gets money
it's the same thing it's a giant hustle
doesn't matter what color you are we've
got over here too we're going to
manipulate this stuff and unfortunately
it's going to be grants and taxpayers
money they end up going into one
individual's pocket not everybody's
great point a great point it's always
the same it's like with the people who
start something startup business and
then they get corrupt cat any right-wing
cities
just think about reparations yes you're
already spending the money it sucks no I
was thinking about how I have to get
bread after this
from the store I'm just happy you're
eating carbs yeah
uh me too
mentioned it's the taxes that are the
issue I don't really care that it's
sturdy and disgusting I kind of thrive
in a chaotic gross environment uh I do
but
um I it's also like the amount of
regulatory Hoops that businesses need to
go through here more so than anywhere
else just to have a business somewhere
where some guy is going to have meth
diarrhea outside yes that's the worst
diarrhea yeah it's not good you can tell
the difference yeah you like we were
playing a game my husband and I we were
walking the dog like that street dump
like what drug was that person on or
were they withdrawing from what drug
based on what that looks like our
audience is starting to get sick well
well welcome to New York baby
uh so if it wasn't like I wouldn't mind
it it wasn't so expensive to live here
I'll be like that should be the selling
point like listen this is like this
place is a steal like it's disgusting
yeah you come here but like it's cheaper
exactly now it's the most expensive
place on Earth it's ridiculously
expensive yeah I would to Circle back
though we were talking about earlier
yeah I think what I was trying to say
was I think it reducing these issues
that these cities have and reducing this
problem to a blue versus red thing as a
small business owner in New York City
I've sat in on these meetings uh you
know outdoor structures was a big one
here in New York I sat for seven hours
on a zoom to speak for three minutes and
I had to listen to a lot of City reps
right and left talk yeah everybody on
the left wanted to protect their their
bike Lanes okay and everybody on the red
just kept on the on the right kept going
well covet's over deal with it you don't
need your outdoor structure anymore both
things were so narrow-minded yeah and I
think I agree with you you do need
balance in these cities you do need a
balance of policies but I don't think
the it's like the right is stepping up
necessarily I don't think some of these
places I think they offer that balance I
think they've given up you can't get it
I'm not giving a pass to the left either
yeah now there's no Republican party in
in New York right now the the difference
between rural areas and cities is City
governments promise everything and they
promise all these things that they can't
provide yeah whereas in rural areas or
in small towns most people are kind of
their own 9-1-1 or or their neighbors
9-1-1 yeah and and so you don't have
those and and I mean you don't have to
live like that you don't have to live
like where you walk your dog yes I guess
what kind of what no I'm just saying
that a society shouldn't be like that
yeah and the idea and the thing that
appalls me the most about it the idea
that women cannot feel safe walking down
the street in a city is it's just
mind-blowing to me and I and I don't
understand why that that's not like a
big women's issue that would be the
biggest one but it's not we have to move
on though I'm getting I'm getting yelled
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else